في غضون الساعات القليلة الماضية
، كانت هناك معركة شرسة هنا على
مشارف كييف ، وهذا هو خط المواجهة
في المعركة من أجل العاصمة الأوكرانية ، حيث
كان العمود الروسي الذي نزل
هنا عبارة عن
شاحنات ومركبات مدرعة مطرقة تمامًا وتحولت إلى
معدن ملتوي.  بينما تحفر القوات الأوكرانية في
القبض على الكرملين وقواته الغزوية
على حين غرة ، انظر إلى هذا ، أعني ما هو
نوع الذخيرة التي يتطلبها القيام بذلك
لسيارة إلى مركبة تعرفها ، وأنا أعلم
أنني أتحدث إلى القادة الأوكرانيين المحليين
هنا  لقد كانوا يقولون
إنهم كانوا يستخدمون صواريخ غربية مضادة للدبابات
لمهاجمة هذه الأعمدة ،
انظر مؤخرًا ،
المعركة لا تزال تدخن ، لا يزال هناك
دخان يخرج من
القادة مثل إسكندر من
الجيش الأوكراني
الذي اعتقد الروس أنهم يستطيعون
السير فيه.  إلى الأراضي الأوكرانية في
موكب منتصر ، أخبرني أنهم كانوا
مخطئين ، لن يحدث ذلك أبدًا ،
أعني أنظر ، أعني أن هذا نوعًا
ما من الكليشيهات تقريبًا ولكن من
الواضح  أحضر شخص ما تذكارًا
من المنزل
كما تعلم ، والآن تم
حرقه والكذب مع حطامهم
في هذه الحالة ، فاشل
هجومًا ترك القوات الأوكرانية
التي صدته واثقة من
أن النصر يمكن أن
يتكرر في جميع أنحاء البلاد مع
تقدم القوات الروسية
بالتأكيد ستفوز أوكرانيا في هذه الحرب ،
أخبرني الكسندر بالطبع أننا سنفوز
وسوف يتعفن الروس هنا ، يقول إن
هذه السيارة هنا من الواضح أنها من
الجيش الروسي ، لقد حصلت على الحرف v
um مرقط على الشريط الجانبي أو
بالطلاء
الذي أعتقد أنه  تشير إلى فوستوك
وهي الكلمة الروسية للشرق
مما
يعني أن هذه المعدات العسكرية
جاءت من الأقسام الشرقية
للجيش الروسي ،
ما كنت أقوله هناك
يبدو كما هو واضح ، لا أريد أن
أريكم هذا كثيرًا ولكن
هناك  الجسد هناك هو جندي روسي
يرقد هناك ميتًا على هذا الجسر ،
يمكنك أن تخبرهم أنهم روس
لأن لديهم
هذا الأسود والأحمر.  وشريط أه جورج البرتقالي
مغطس فوقهم وهو
علامة رمز للجيش الروسي
نعم ذخيرة
الإسكندر ، لا
شيء فظيع أن نرى
الوحشية القاتمة
للحرب
بالنسبة للأوكرانيين وبالطبع بالنسبة
للروس وكذلك التضحية التي
يتم دفعها من قبل  كل الجوانب في هذا
الهدر الكامل للحياة
موجودة هنا لكي نراها جميعًا